Speaker 1: This has really been one of the most
remarkable weeks in this Jan. six investigation
being carried out by the House Committee because
not only did we learn about the existence of all
of these different documents and by this week, I
mean, in the last seven days, in the last week,
not necessarily this calendar week,
Speaker 2: the PowerPoint outlining
Speaker 1: how to do the coup, which we talked
about on Monday, but also these text messages
received by Mark Meadows, who increasingly seemed
to sort of be an important nexus in Donald Trump's
state of mind at the time and what he was doing.
Speaker 2: And this is going several
Speaker 1: layers deeper and deeper now. There are
increased calls for Ivanka Trump's text messages
to be obtained Ivanka Trump, of course, the adult
daughter of Donald Trump, who advised him. If you
can imagine something more insane during the Trump
Speaker 2: administration even sat in
Speaker 1: for Trump's secretary of state at
the G8 or G20, I never remember which it is.
The Independent now reports that there are
calls issued for Ivanka's texts from January 6th
to be released. Why? Well, because South Carolina
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham revealed Ivanka
Speaker 2: was a pass through to Donald
Speaker 1: Trump on that day.
Speaker 2: Texts handed over
Speaker 1: so
Speaker 2: far from Mark
Speaker 1: Meadows
Speaker 2: show that Don
Speaker 1: Jr. was in touch, with Mark Meadows
Speaker 2: saying, This looks
Speaker 1: terrible. We looked at the
text yesterday and the day before. He's got to
go out there, he's got to tell them to go home,
et cetera, et cetera. Graham has said
he wasn't texting with Mark Meadows,
Speaker 2: but says he spoke to Ivanka
Speaker 1: Trump and asked her to send
a message to Donald Trump, saying Tell the
people to leave. Now, of course, that that has
Speaker 2: been revealed a
Speaker 1: previously unknown
that Ivanka was in the loop. Now there
are calls from a whole number of people,
Speaker 2: including Democrats
Speaker 1: and some Republicans,
to see Ivanka Trump's text messages as well. So
first of all, should we see those texts? Yes,
those have to be obtained. We'll see if the House
Committee is able to do it. Number two, the family
Speaker 2: dynamics that all of this is exposing
Speaker 1: are pretty remarkable. I mean,
Don Jr. was
Speaker 2: texting Mark Meadows to ask him
Speaker 1: to tell his dad to call off
the domestic terrorists on January 6th.
Lindsey was able Lindsey Graham was able to speak
to a banker who I guess could get a hold of her
dad. For whatever reason, Don Jr. couldn't,
but Ivanka could. And none of it's really
Speaker 2: surprising whether the
Speaker 1: reasons are what we've
known about Trump's relationships with his sons
as compared to his relationship with Ivanka, which
sometimes actually seemed to go too far and start
bordering on a little bit creepy. Like when he
Speaker 2: said, If
Speaker 1: we weren't related, I would be dating
Ivanka, something like that. Maybe it has to do
with just the strained relationship with the boys.
Speaker 2: It's all bizarre.
Speaker 1: And then the last
thing that I think shouldn't be ignored.
Speaker 2: Is whether it's possible
Speaker 1: that the tax Don
Jr. sent to Mark Meadows
Speaker 2: might have been to
create a cover in a sense and
Speaker 1: creating some kind of paper trail where
Don Jr. could say no, look, I knew it was bad.
I wasn't in instigating or inciting at
all. Look at what I texted Mark Meadows,
maybe knowing that it would make no difference to
his dad one way or the other. The other thing is,
Lindsey Graham isn't always the most
honest person, either, so everything he
Speaker 2: says we should take
Speaker 1: with a grain of
salt. At the end of the day,
Speaker 2: I wish there was
a chance that these people
Speaker 1: would actually
Speaker 2: face real consequences.
Speaker 1: I know yesterday in our interview,
Michael told Michael Cohen told me they
will. I just don't see it. I just don't see
it. The great thing is whether these people
Speaker 2: are lying or telling the truth,
Speaker 1: they do seem increasingly willing to
turn on each other to try to save themselves,
and that's something that we
need to take advantage of.
Speaker 2: On the left, we're going
to talk about that a little bit more
Speaker 1: on the last segment today. Also
lastly, does anybody believe Jared Kushner's
fingerprints aren't all over this thing?
I think they clearly are, but he's mostly
stayed out of the discussion so far that
that may change. We'll have to wait and see a